you know I've been doing YouTube for
nine years almost ten and I've read a
lot of weird comments in my days but
this but this subreddit takes the price
I present to you cursed comments
consider yourself warned
hey number neighbor we have the same
phone number except yours is one digit
about mine what's up
I'm not sure how to read that but I wish
someone would write me number
neighborhood be so funny I could be like
hey brofist yeah that was funny
who should a self-driving car kill A or
B if you drift you should be able to
take out both of them epic
would you answer a or B both thank you
curse comment actual superheroes they
killed my dad
oh god this is so edgy a lot changes
depending on who speaks first this is so
deep and thought-provoking so I
recommend it is sub rated my god I'm
gonna blame him
hi I got my account back just in case I
ever get hacked again here's the only
nude photo I've ever taken can threaten
me with it now get a life Lord forgive
me before what I'm about to do that's
pretty hot on ironically like I'd
freaking done jumping off buildings how
high is too high it was originally a
team project I have a bad feeling about
this video if school was a game what
would be some loading screen tips Oh No
why is Billy a leash brother dating
someone that looks exactly like Billy
I've seen this super weird because Billy
isn't 18 ah stop this is why we need to
remove all comments this is I want
nothing more being kissed in your sleep
is like the purest form of love unless
that's funny it's true your heartbeat is
probably perfectly synchronized with
someone else's oh that's true that's so
nice especially if you're dead stop stop
no more comment I name my dog five miles
so I can tell people I walk five miles
every day I ran over fire Oh God
stop sigh help me
why you recommend this what would you do
if you found me in your fridge how to be
extremely scared because the other
bodies in my fridge don't smile Danny
DeVito will die in your lifetime
not if I what's the difference between a
child and a hooker I don't know Wow you
sick freak some are good a lot of them I
don't condone whatsoever just so we're
clear my legal peer representation team
it's read the text okay I don't help
help why do I make a life harder for
myself Jeanne I shall grant you three
wishes me I wish my dog could talk
Jeanne done me petting my dog hey buddy
you've got two wishes first I want my
balls back second I want his gun
I'm sorry Edgar I'm sorry you were
humping literally everything I don't do
that oh no never mind being kissed while
you're asleep is one of the purest form
of love air it is again okay unless
you're in prison I like that even better
that's hilarious
well I got two different people made
this post they thought it was so nice
this being kissed while asleep it shook
that's really weird I don't understand
this is not the purest form of love at
all imagine you get shot and your friend
with you like don't worry bro any jacks
off in hand smears BP juice he's not all
over and wound and it instantly heals
no I will not know I think I will not
imagine it sounds like some terrible mod
for like Battlefield or something
Tennessee man accused of dippin
testicles in customer salsa before
online delivery you a mega ho if you can
taste the hit of ball sack in some
Mexican to be fair yes I mean that's
impressive hmm it should dip their balls
in this Karen come try this all set Oh
what someone dip a ball I tasted hello
hello my salsa myself sir taste the ball
sack help help I think that's probably
what happened that's just my theory but
did you know there is a skeleton inside
you right now you don't have a skeleton
inside you you're a brain you are inside
a skeleton you are piloting a bone mech
that's using meat armor I've seen this
before
and this is not a cursed car but it
actually gives me a little sense of
pride but I'm a little bit of anime
inside of me smash like if you agree
what if your teeth were naturally
flaccid and got hard when you got hungry
mom I'm not hungry
honey I see your heart just eat it
humanity was a mistake let's just get
real here Americans we're gonna raid
area 51 Europeans we have nothing to
raid the Vatican archives the Vatican
archives
it's got 4.4 rating oh my god what do we
call the event on Facebook storm the
Vatican archives they can't molest us
all but cursed boots so these shoes make
dog footprints and the comment is I have
these slowly it's so funny to see my
neighbor blame the dogs for no
it sports Oh God that's hilarious
I wish I had more time if I had free
time this is how I would spend it my
girlfriend works in a sushi restaurant
she's pretty
I've seen enough hentai to know where
this is going
hey I'm unvaccinated my superpowers
include spreading diseases I don't have
do they make these in adult sizes oh
wait there's no need
bra these are not funny by the way let's
just be clear with that if I'm laughing
it's out of a nervous reaction okay
that's it just so we're clear epic
i-21 male have a microt peep you ask me
anything I'm pretty depressed about it
maybe there's a girl out there with a
microbe no your pee pee will be gifted
with an extra inch what if I'm a girl
that click go I click going bangles nope
I had it up this is a video that ends at
all I can feel it now notes of vodka
hints of fresh lemon a raspberry finish
our findings from tasting of this
season's that one dollar vodka raspberry
lemonade harvest my mother was murdered
in one of your restaurants and the
killer was never found
is this real it's real we're featuring
than one dollar vodka raspberry lemonade
the entire month of June women warned
not to put ice lollies in their
flip-flop to cool off during heatwave ah
no no right who writes these articles
Jesus pokey main please stop asking for
my bathwater I take showers is used
mouthwash an option I have officially
lost hope in humanity after going
through the subreddit there's no point
in me even continuing it makes no
difference
elizabeth ii firing a british l85 battle
rifle in 1993 it's a nice gun but i
think we'll just go with a car crime no
stop when you break into area 51 and you
see that alien who anal probe you from
your dream it's payback time gamers
what if glass licked your feet when you
stepped on it I would do a split
every day we stray further from God's
grace I think the problem is the first
person who asks the question
don't ask why I had this it's I had
water on my desk random acts of kindness
softly kiss the postman's fingers when
he puts the through the door to let him
know that you're thankful for his gifts
Wow
only a matter of time before a no stop
stop it was already horrible doctors
have read it where what are the most
haunting last words you ever heard of
patients say every time you yawn you're
putting goes peepee in your mouth
Oh God
probably made other people yawn by doing
a Guinness Book of World Records holds
the records for being the book most
often stolen from public libraries well
is those are one of the most sold books
as well I think Guinness Guinness but
seriously how do you sneak out such a
big and heavy book same way you get the
record for largest anal cavity ah
[Music]
dentists care Wow is he supporting her
entire weight is my stop
she pays oh no because nothing starts
your day off right
like Darth Vader trying heavily over
your naked body I Loki kind of want this
low-key guys kind of wanna buy this a
Goomba can't be in smash he has no arms
explain this scientist simple that's not
up oh no oh god oh god stop boom by
Kenta peepee but then how can Goomba
habibi food-for-thought looks comfy
who said Ferraris aren't family cars
haha great can wait for the horrible
comet to show up because air from the
grill is I verted out of those channels
that baby would be launched out at
sufficiently high speed Oh God fantastic
that's the whole read it summarize yeah
you're right but shut up we don't want
to hear it
I'm done I just want to say I am sorry I
apologize I might as well make my
apology video now this was irresponsible
I do not condone this sense of humor
these are not jokes they're not funny
and if I laughed it was purely a gag
reflex to how terrible these jokes were
they were not even jokes I don't like it
alright guys thanks for watching this I
hope you feel
better about yourself well at least from
now on it can't get worse than this
unless you buy a hundred million Club
merge epically guys these will disappear
soon so do it now or never just letting
you know represent that comes like
feedback see you gamers I would
appreciate it because let's get real
this video is not getting it see you
gamers next time bye bye bye bye gamers
well you haven't tried to pursue milady
at City after 50 million outros much now
just now it's still relevant just down a
bit